what's going on everybody welcome to
another Kaggle tutorial also I'm going
to be quite throwing this one at the end
of the machine learning tutorial series
the kind of in-depth practical series so
while I was poking around this data
science Bowl I also noticed that they
put up this dog's verse cats Redux
kernels edition and so that's we're
going to run through in this one simply
because it's a really simple
classification task of as you might
guess dogs vs. cats just identifying
whether there's a dog or a cat in the
picture this one's kind of incorrect in
that none of the pictures should have
both a dog and a cat in them but anyway
that's what we're going to be doing so
if you don't have a kaggle account go
ahead make it make one come to data
you'll have to accept the terms and all
that when you come here but otherwise
make downloads about seven eight hundred
megabytes before you download it in it
or before you extract it rather and then
after that it's I forget how large it is
but it's like I think that training is
twenty-five thousand files and the
testing is twelve thousand five hundred
or something
Oh says it right there Wow once that was
on-screen as yes it sure was anyway yes
there you have it
so that's what we're me doing so if you
need to pause the video whatever get
everything downloaded and extracted and
just kind of keep in mind where you've
got it all right once you're ready to
rumble we're going to come over here and
we're going to get started so because
I'm going to throw this at the end of
the ML series I'm just going to note
that up to this point you really should
have tensorflow
so pip install tender file you should
also have CF learn pip install PS learn
and I'm also going to use this key qdm
it's just a really kind of fancy way to
have pretty output while you're loading
it was suggested to me by one of my
viewers so I thought hey that's actually
pretty cool so I'm going to use it you
don't have to you can just where we and
you just you can use it in any kind of
for loop basically as you it over the
whatever the iterable is you just use t
qdm so wherever we do that if you don't
want to do it just don't
it simple enough alrighty so the first
part is just simple pre-processing so
we're going to bring in the data and do
some pre-processing against this data so
the first thing we're going to do is
let's just make some imports so we're
going to import CV to for just resizing
the image basically I'm going to import
numpy as NP we're going to import OS
we're going to from random we're going
to import shuffle so we can shuffle our
data no tie for arrays obviously OS so
we can play with the directories
shuffled so we can shuffle and then from
C qdm import to import tqm for
professional looping with a progress bar
now we're ready to find some contents
train der I'll fill these in in a moment
but train der tester we're going to say
image image size and for now I'll just
say 50 here and then LR for learning
rate 1e negative 3 so that's 0.01 all
right so the trainer is wherever you've
extracted these files to I'm just going
to copy and paste minds don't feel like
typing it all out and many of you
probably have the exact same path so
paste and I'm going to copy over here
paste cool so this is where I've
extracted the data this isn't
necessarily where yours is just wherever
you've extracted the data that's what
needs to be in there
image size that's what we're going to
resize the images to they're not all the
same size some of them and this is 50 as
in 50 by 50 so not all these images are
a perfect square but we're going to make
them a perfect square so there's going
to be a little bit of trying to take
distortion probably but that's that's ok
finally we have one more parameter and
that's going to model name we're going
to use this just because as we go
through this we're going to kind of
tweak a few things and maybe change some
things it's useful to have some sort of
model name that way when you save the
model you can remember what was this
model to my knowledge you can't just
like in tensorflow query a model and get
like how many layers and how many
there might be a way like I want to be
surprised surely the model file has in
there maybe you can just open it up I
don't really know actually
but regardless if you try to load a
model into a neural net that's not the
same dimensions you're going to problems
so I like to save them as something
somewhat useful so I'm just going to
call this first one dogs first cats -
some formatting - some more formatting
done model and then we'll do this dot
format and I'll just for now we'll save
learning rate and then let's just say
this is a to cond basic for this
tutorial so - convolutional layers and
then we're just going to say basic
because we're basic continuing along so
the first order of business now is to
process the data what we have right now
is once you've extracted data is all
these images that are labeled by number
I think it's cat dot one and then kappa
2 kappa 3 and so on and dog dot 1 in dog
attitudes so so what we need to do and
they're color images and all that so
what we're going to do is we need to
load in the images and then as all
machine learning goes you've got your
features and your labels well for the
features we're going to convert just to
a numpy grayscale array
done that's the 2d array for the image
luckily these are 2d images if you've
been following the other candle example
for the medical data that's 3d data
we're trying to use a 3d continent super
expensive anyway so yeah just simple 2d
grayscale data and then the label is
either dog or cat which obviously is not
accessible means that's b1 hot so to do
that we're going to convert to we're
going to say you know the one
hunter-reay
basically this first value is going to
be Katniss the second value will be
dogness so a cat would be you know all
Katniss zero dog disks and a dog's
classification will be zero Katniss all
dog news ok so we're going to define
labels image so this will be a function
it's going to take an image it's
actually an image path that's okay we're
going to say now the word underscore
label is going to equal two image
lips we're going to split by a period
and then we're going to go back three
possibly let me check that but what
we'll see how that goes
gifts word underscore label T equals cat
we're going to just keep this all online
colon return right Paul cat zero dog of
I'm in LS word label equals dog we
return zero Katniss Bulldog Oh yep we
don't delete it all okay so that's our
label image invalid syntax so comparison
operator is not Sonic there we are
continuing along now we need one more
helper function and that's going to be
to create basically create the train
data that's actually going to use this
so define and create underscore and this
is kind of small on the screen make this
a little bigger
oh yeah now we're cooking maybe that's
too big but let me do this real quick
what just fine and then we're going to
say create trains probably watch
functionally right anyway in this this
video great train data and then what are
we going to do well first we're going to
a train on a short data equals an empty
list then we're going to say for image
in and again this is one of the examples
whereas TQ DM encasing whatever the
iterable is going to be but in our case
it's OS that list or whatever the
trainer was so again if you don't want
to use TC DM or I don't think T TDM is
available in the kernels on Kaggle so I
don't know but anyway just just remove
the whole TQ DM super simple
so for the image in there what do we
want to do well we're going to say the
label equals label underscore image min
and then what we're going to do yes so
for example I yes the negative three
should be right because you've got it'll
be I know you everyone else probably
doesn't paying any attention to this
anymore but you're gonna have dogs dot
ninety three dot and I think they're PNG
so you split by a period the negative
first test is here the negative rather
than yeah the negative first estimate
here negative two will be here and
negative 3 will be here that's that's
the the word label that we want I know
you guys are still thinking about that
I'm sure okay well we're gonna pass
equal to s top cap dot G all right and
we're enjoying trained dirt and whatever
that image actually is like it's the
full path that I mentioned I'm going to
loaded in with CB to image equals CA v2
dot M lead and we're going to read the
pack and we're going to read this in as
a CB to dot M read underscore grayscale
now we're going to resize it week's also
just in case this in a resize as well so
I think I will actually CBC dot resize
all of this and then but in tuple form
it's going to be the constant we have up
here emic size so this will be an image
size by image size like so beautiful now
that gives us the image data so all
we're going to do at this point is rain
and actually let's say we said trained a
sickle called the screening data
training data dot a pen and we will
append the numpy array of the image data
and then also the rule actually look
like sure they learn the pie right just
for this to be absolutely certain I
should pretty sure the image data
probably already is a numpy array or at
least acceptable our label definitely
wasn't weird you want to make sure
everything's in the right an umpire
right okay once we've done that now what
we want to do is shuffle the data so
shuffle and shuffle happens two
variables in place so you don't need to
redefine them in fact if you did I'm
pretty sure it doesn't work now we're
going to save it just in case and we'll
just call it train data dot n py4 numpy
file and then training that is what's
being saved and then we will also return
training data okay so every time we
train data basically you should only
need to do this process one time and so
that first time we will just return the
training data anyway but we're also
going to save it that way in the future
if we want to run this we don't need to
actually rerun the function we can just
load in the train data dot numpy file
the only time you would ever have to run
this the second time is if you change
image size so if you wanted rather than
a fitting by 50 maybe 100 by 100 or
something like that which we probably
won't change the image image size here
we're also going to mess with the
network size video by babies should be
pretty acceptable even fifty-five videos
kind of on a larger side although I
don't know in the last year what people
are typically doing but trusting like
twenty six twenty sixteen people were
doing pretty small images so fifty bucks
it is kind of big relatively okay so
that's it here what we're going to do in
the next tutorials actually do all the
processing of the data and then either
in that one will start the continent or
in the one after that will do the
continent we probably can actually just
write out the continent in the next one
actually we're probably just going to
copy and paste the content from the TF
learn tutorial there's no reason to
rewrite it out so yeah I think we'll
actually just do that and anybody who
doesn't understand it can go to the
National tutorial where we explained it
anyway that's what you have to look
forward to if you've got questions
comments concerns whatever up to this
point feel free to leave them below
otherwise I'll see you in the next video
Oh